we are used to the conventional wisdom
but the only thing that matters in
television are these live events sports
events awards shows and your point was
if I understood correctly that even that
is not going to save TV channels you're
just going to you're going to see more
and more advertising dollars move to
where eyeballs are and that's going
online and in addition consumers are
moving too over the top and nonlinear
viewing you realize Netflix is going to
spend three billion dollars in original
content programming Amazon's increasing
an investment in the original content
programming to a billion and a half so
you have non ad-supported sources of
revenue are popping up excuse me non
ad-supported sources of content great
content house of cards etc transition
popping up everywhere I think that all
spells bad news for television as we
know it but does it mean if we're
looking at what Netflix is paying to
acquire a content and the disappearance
of ad sales is video production in
general what are you talking movies TV
is that going to become a fee-only
service well it's a great time to be a
writer or someone who's trying to
green-light a script there's going to be
more original scripted series this year
than I think in the history of
television it's just not a great time to
be in the business of selling eyeballs
on an ad-supported model HBO great
business Netflix great business amazon
media might be a great business trying
to get a ton of people to show up and
then selling commercials to beer
companies that's it gonna be a difficult
business does that mean the three of us
are gonna be out of a job no it's
because I'm working on a script right
now about an amazing news man trapped on
a show with two other people trying to
break through but look at look at okay
and this is 0 sense it but look at where
this program has had a bite-sized great
content available on your side Bloomberg
has the most traffic site in business
media and this is you are headed to
where the buck the puck has had it let
me ask you a question well I like it
where the puck is said Olivia I want you
to jump in here to the people in the
audience last night want to be movie
stars or TV stars TVs ten times the size
of the business you get invited to
cooler parties when you're a movie star
so you know you're gonna get that be
true what movie to Jennifer Anniston
Star in France will that be true you get
invited a better team I mean we've got
Kevin Spacey doing amazing original
programming on Netflix how long is it
true that Hollywood's damn it
much it's much easier to go downstream
it's much easier for a luxury brand to
become a fusion or a mass brand than the
other way it's harder for TV star to
become a movie star once a movie star
stops get invited stops getting about it
the Oscars he or she can get a TV show
so if it's an ocean of lame who's
watching one of the demographics of the
Oscar viewer the Oscar still do get a
huge audience it's still oh no no I
would say it's it's in the hundreds of
millions it's got to be the hundreds of
millions so it's still it's like Janet
yellen's testimony yeah yes I just live
television what if we did a red carpet
on the way into Janet yellen's testimony
think you would be amazing at that and
guess what it would do very well on
digital no I just mr. bike for Barney
Frank Barney Frank who are you wearing
to see yeah that's right oh no this
brings us tonight Leslie to our Twitter
question the day do agree with Scott
Galloway was it a fashion show amidst an
ocean of lame do the Oscars matter
here's some of the answers first the
Oscars matter because they reflect
certain societal trends preferences and
prejudices perhaps when our guests
earlier this morn are Scott said how
surprised he was it was so political the
second answer it matters because
indulgence is mocking the hard-working
core of the world a hundred thousand
pound party bag outrageous third and
final answer oscars are not fully
objective Leonardo DiCaprio still
doesn't have one where are we going
sounds like that person is not fully
objective about Leonardo DiCaprio no
there it is horseshoe beds who knows he
never one for Titanic but that year was
the highest viewership right because all
right big franchise i watch Titanic yes
there with my son great movie wonderful
movie is aged well it's a fantastic film
did he know that Daytona was on Oscars
most disconnected ever ever yesterday
fewer box office receipts of the of the
denominators nominated movies in the
history of the Oscars more diskin a
disconnected from its totally passé
alignment really totally just did you
see Birdman or well maybe the people at
this table because we live on the coast
but Birdman and the grand Budapest hotel
that's the industry steering I was fab
great cultural wars of America Selma and
sniper shut out no but that's the point
about a big franchise big franchise what
makes money for the studio big franchise
like Titanic is what brings in the
audience for the viewers and everybody
who won the Oscars with first-time
winner